MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20 Special Relativity.
In this section, we're going
to talk about the emission
and the absorption of photons.
So you can think
about a scenario
where you have an atom
which emits a photon,
like in this picture here.
And to create a new atom,
which we call the atom prime,
in the absorption process,
you have a collision
between a photon and the atom.
And you make a new atom,
again, indicated by a prime.
So I want you to actually work
this out in two activities.
The first one is on absorption.
So here we have a stationary
particle, the atom,
with a mass M0, and
it's struck by a photon.
We have this scenario here.
And the photon has an
energy, Q, and becomes--
and there's a new particle
coming out with the rest mass
M0 prime and
recoiling velocity, it
has to have some
sort of momentum,
v. And so the question
is, how can we
now find the mass of this new
particle and the velocity?
So please stop the video,
and try to work this out.
So the way to work this out is
by writing energy and momentum
equation.
You can do this just
with a four-vector.
even though we are not
performing any Lorentz
transformation in this
part, you can just
write on the four-vector.
And this needs to
be conserved energy.
And momentum need to be
conserved in this correlation.
All right, so we have the
mass of this initial particle
at rest.
So the energy is M 0 C square.
The energy of the photon is
Q. The momentum of the photon
is Q over c.
And so then the final particle--
the outcoming new particle
has its own mass,
but it has a boost.
So the total energy is M 0
prime gamma using the velocity
of this particle, C square.
And the momentum is M 0
prime gamma times v. So
that's after the correlation.
And so then you can
use the energy relation
in order to get to the mass.
This is a function
of the velocity here.
And you can get the velocity
by looking at the momentum.
So you basically solve for this
v or v over c in this case.
And then if you want, you
can add this back in here
in order to get the
mass as a function
of the mass of the
initial particle
and the energy of the photon.
The second example
now is the emission.
So here we have a stationary
atom with a rest mass M0.
And it emits the
photon, this energy Q.
And it becomes the new
atom with rest mass
M0 prime and recoiling
with the velocity.
Now given the two masses, what
is the energy of the photon?
Q.
So we set this up in
the same way as before.
Now we start with
this particle at rest.
And the energy is M 0 c squared.
Momentum is 0.
And that's equal to
the energy and momentum
of the new particle and the
photon, in the very same way
as we set this up before.
So now what you
want to do here is
use our invariants of the
four-vector using the energy
and momentum relation.
So the mass of this new particle
times c square squared is equal
to the energy squared .
The energy squared-- you
just bring this over here--
is M0 c squared minus Q squared.
And then the momentum is
simply of this new particle,
is simply Q square.
This you cannot solve for Q.
And you find this relation here.
So that's the energy
of the outgoing photon.
If you now define Q0 as
the difference in masses
or the difference of the
masses times c square,
then you can write the
energy of the photon
as Q0 times 1 minus
Q0 over 2M c square.
And that's always smaller
than the difference in masses.
So if you now analyze this
and look at this some more
and try to understand
what it means,
what we find is that the
emission and the absorption,
they only occur at
a very precise value
of the energy of the photon.
It also means that an
emitted photon can only
be reabsorbed if the
particles are moving
with just the right velocity.
So if you're an atom,
and the photon goes out,
and your neighboring atom is
just sitting there next to you
at rest as you were at
rest before, it is not
able to reabsorb the photon.
So we learned just by using
special relativity quite a bit
about the physics
involved in absorption
and emission of photons.